[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اجرت كثره ازقه
السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القاهره محادثات مع عدد من
المسؤولين المصريين وممثلين عن مختلف
القوى السياسيه من بينها التحالف الوطني
لدعم الشرعيه
وتناولت هذه المحادثات تطورات الوضع
السياسي في البلاد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقشه في محورين ما دلالات المواقف
المصريه الرسميه التي رافقت بدء مباحثات
كثيرا في القاهره
وهل الاسراع في انهاء المرحله الانتقاليه
المعلنه بعد الانقلاب العسكري في مصر كفيل
وحده في تحقيق الاستقرار
استبق المسئولون المصريون محادثاتهم مع
كاترين اشتون منسقه السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بتحركات لافته ووزير
الدفاع الفريق عبد الفتاح السيسي دعا الى
الاسراع في انهاء المرحله الانتقاليه طبقا
لخريطه الطريق المعارضه من جانبه كما اجرى
في الرئاسه المصريه حوار حوار مع مجموعه
من الشباب وصفوا بانهم منشقون عن جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين ويقع هذا فيما تطلق
دعوات لمظاهرات جديده مناهضه الانقلاب في
ذكر السادس من اكتوبر ما يضع علامات
استفهام حول امكانيه تحقيق مصالحه في مصر
مسؤوله السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي كاثرين اشتون في مصر للمره
الثالثه منذ الثلاثين يونيو محادثاتها كما
في المرات السابقه لا تقتصر على المسؤولين
في الحكومه والرئاسه و مؤسسه الجيش بل
تشمل ايضا قوى سياسيه وشخصيات من تحالف
دعم الشرعيه المطالبين بعوده الرئيس
المعزول
تحدثت مصادر عن محاوله اشت لاستكشاف فرص
العوده الى انتقال للسلطه تساهم فيه جميع
الاطراف امر يبدو شبه مستحيل في الوضع
السياسي الحالي تزامنا مع اصرار الحكومه
الجديده على رفض اي مبادره اجنبيه
واعتبرها تدخلا في شان داخلي المصري بيد
انه ليس سرا ان ثمه ضغوطا داخليه وخارجيه
على السلطه الجديده جاءت زياره اشتون بعد
ساعات من تصريحات القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه عبد الفتاح السيسي الذي صعد نجمه
بعد عزل مرسي قال انه لا بد من الاسراع في
انهاء المرحله الانتقاليه واكد ان مؤسسه
الجيش ستبقى على الحياد في اي انتخابات
مقبله في القوات المسلحه كمؤسسه عسكريه لم
تدعم احد
ابدا كل واحد انتو شعب مصر لكن بوش لا
اقول لك ليه لان دي مسؤوليه اخلاقيه و
وطنيه ودينيه
يشكل كثيرا انصار الرئيس المعزول في ذلك
فقد وعد العسكر وقبيل مظاهرات الثلاثين من
يونيو الماضي بعدم تدخل ولكنهم تدخلوا في
الثالث من يوليو في مناخ غير مستقر بسبب
المظاهرات والاعتقالات بل وحتى مواجهات
مسلحه في اكثر من مكان لا تبدو فرص او
غيرها في خفض درجه الاحتقان ممكنه الدستور
الموعود نفسه يمر بازمه بسبب خلافات داخل
لجنه الخمسين بشان مواد مرتبطه بالهويه
الاسلاميه ووضع الجيش في الدستور مسلسل
المظاهره المعاديه للانقلاب ليتوقف هناك
دعوه لمظاهرات حاشده بمناسبه ذكرى حرب
السادس من اكتوبر ولا يعرف هل ستنتهي دون
مواجهه لقاء المستشار الاعلامي للرئيس
احمد المسلماني مع مجموعه من شباب الاخوان
المنشقين تحت عنوان جهود المصالحه قد لا
يغير شيئا في الشرق الذي حدث في البلد فهو
لم يلتقي بالقوه التي تحرك الشارع الطريق
الى تنفيذ خريطه الطريق مليئه بالمطبات
ولا يعرف اين تنتهي حدوده ولا الثمن الذي
سيدفعه المصريون في سبيل الوصول اليها
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
مختار كامل رئيس تحالف المصريين
الامريكيين
ومعنا هنا في الاستديو الاستاذ عزام نائب
رئيس حزب الوسط والمنسق العام لجبهه
الضمير مرحبا ب ضيفينا الكريمين تختار
كامل
للمره الثالثه منذ الثلاثين من يونيو
اشتغل في القاهره برايك هل جاءت مع ومعها
جديد
اه لا اعتقد ان قد جاءت ومع جديد لان كل
الاقتراحات
الخاصه باحتمال التسويه بين الاطراف
المتنازعه قد استنفذت تقريبا ولكنها جاءت
لكي تعطي اشاره الى ان هناك قلقا في الغرب
لما يجري في مصر وايضا
يعني بعض النقط على الحروف وتقول اننا
مهتمون
انما اه يعني سوف نحافظ على توازنات معينه
في المشهد السياسي المصري وانا حريصون جدا
على عدم تدهور الدوله المصريه
والقضاء على احتمالات الجاريه
مهتمون واه نحافظ على التوازنات كما تقول
مهمه في المشهد المصري مهتمون بماذا هل
بامره الديمقراطيه ام بترشيح وجود الجيش
سيطرته على المشهد المصري وصل ربما مشهد
الديمقراطي اه اه قد يكون فقط وليس اكثر
والله سؤالكم عقد في الدقيقتين وانا عليها
اللي هو اهم حاجه في نظر الغرب هو طبعا
مصالح الغرب مصالح الغرب تاتي عن طريق
تحقيق نوع من الاستقرار في مصر ومنع
انهيار الدوله المصريه ياتي ذلك اه
بناء على ذلك الغرب يتصور ان ال العسكريين
ان القيادات الجيش متحالفه مع الدوله
العميقه او غير متحالفه لن تستطيع ان تقضي
على التيار الاسلامي ويعرفون في نفس الوقت
ان التيار الاسلامي لن يستطيع اطلاقا ان
يفرض ارادته على ال الاجهزه الامنيه وما
الى ذلك وبالتالي الغرب هذا ما قصدته
بمحاوله يعني ضبط التوازنات الغرب يحاول
ان يقنع الاطراف المعنيه بان تدخل في نوع
من الائتلاف ولو ان الغرب في نفس الوقت
يدرك ماذا صعوبه ذلك ويدرك انه في الوقت
الحالي مثل هذه الجهود ربما سوف تفشل لا
ننسى ايضا ان هناك قوه اقليميه مهمه وهي
دول خليجيه وانا فيها السعوديه هذه القوه
تساند الجهاز العسكري والامني بقوه وتساند
عناصر الدوله العميقه بقوه وهذه القوه
الاقليميه
يعني ترسل او تبعث بكثير من الدولارات
الحيويه جدا للترتيبات الحاليه في مصر
وانا اتصور ان هذا الامارات سوف تقول
مشروطه ب يعني بتحقيق سياده معينه
للسلطه معينه ومنع تطور الثوره الى اه
مسار ديمقراطي
ومنع الاخوان المسلمين من الوصول الى
السلطه ما اذا كانوا سوف يكون في ذلك ام
لا هذا ما ستجيب عنه الاحداث في المستقبل
هل من التفتيح السياسي
التعويل على الغرب الذي يرفع رايه
الديمقراطيه ويتشدق يوميا بالدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه والمسار الديمقراطى فى مصر هل
يمكن التعويل على هذا الغرب التي تربطها
مصالح قويه مصر ومن يعني يكون هذه المصالح
هو الجيش وبالتالي التعويل على هذا الغرب
ضرب من العبث
عشرين على حضرتك انا متفق مع ما قاله
الاستاذ كامل ان الغرب لا يهم في الاخر
الا مصالح ولكن هو دائما عنده ازمه ما بين
المصالحه التي يديرها السياسيين في الغرب
والشعوب والقيم التي يسوقها للشعوب
الديمقراطيه والحقوق الحريه ودعني هنا
اذكر محطتين قبل ما خرج على المشهد الكلي
انه بعض الفور كان ضعيف الى البرلمان
الاوروبي مرتين مره شهر مايو 2011 كنت
وكيل الحزب الحضاره وكنت في حوالي طناشر
مصري من سياسيه مختلفه والتقييم دعوتهم
الكتل السياسيه كثيره جدا في البرلمان
الاوروبي وكان الحديث هنا كان نحن قلنا
لهم انتم مبارك ثلاثين سنه اخرى عليه ال
انه كان احنا يقولون احنا محتاجين مشاركه
مصر كما استقبل على مستوى لدى في العلاقه
بين ال مشروع جديد اسمه
دوراند لس يعني كلما تقدمت في الديمقراطيه
وحقوق الانسان اكثر
اذا توقفتم عن هذا لن يساعد احنا هذا
الكلام مشروط يعني انت
الثوره
نحن وان حددها لكن الكلام اللي بدها يناقض
موقفكم مبارك
الحاجه مهمه جدا هلا احنا اخطانا الشديد
في دعم
والاستبداد واحنا بدنا
وبالتالي انا بضع هذا السؤال الى
اذا ك اذا كانوا اخطائه في عهد المبارك
بدعم الديكتاتوريه والزام السلطوي الفاسد
كيف الان يقفون على المسافه
يعني معظم هذه الاجتماعات التي تحدث
يعني مبادره لنهايه او طلب جاء من السلطه
الانقلاب العام للامم المتحده
ورغم انه التقاها الفهم هناك او شيء وطلب
منه القدوم هذا وارد يعني اه اه وخصوصا
نحن لا نعول على الغرب وعلى الغرب نحن
نعول على الصعيد في الشارع ولكن يطرح يعني
انا حضرت جزء من هذه ال اه يعني ال
التفاوضيه مع الاوروبيين عن التحالف
الوطني اه ما يقال انه اترك الشوارع
والميادين احنا عزيز
وان شاء الله كويس هذا الكلام يسند
الانقلاب في الامر
يعني كيف
انفسنا بعد مبارك نحن جئنا بالثوره
المصريه والى الاتحاد الاوروبي ياخد
سياسيه جديده على دعم الديمقراطيه
والحريات انتم الان
لم يخطئوا وربما اخطاوا الناحيه التكتيكيه
في التعامل مع النظام المبارك وما كما
نتمكن من حلها لكنه لم يحضروا في التعامل
مع القضيه الاساس هي طبيعه علاقته مع
المؤسسه العسكريه عصب النظام المصري اسمح
لي لا انت كيف يمكن ان الان وهي تقول بعد
لقائها مع شيخ الازهر بانها
اولا
اكبر شريك الاقتصادي وليس عسكري والولايات
المتحده ولذلك انا ادعوا الناس
ك بالاقتصاد المصري الان الى التفاهم
الولايات المتحده مختلف الولايات المتحده
احنا عندنا التطور بالطريق الانقلاب
العسكري
المؤسسه العسكريه او الحاجه
بسبب العربي امن اسرائيل اسرائيل نمره
اثنين
لمحاربه الارهاب وهكذا في الامم المتحده
وحرمه الارهاب احنا بنسميه العربي القضاء
على المقاومه
ما يحدث الان الاجل او من تصريحات او من
محاوله لصناعه هناك حزمه من الاجراءات
السياسيه الانقلابيين بعد
الخلاف يريدون ان يستنبط التظاهرات سته
اكتوبر او 10 اكتوبر تحصل مشاعر خطر شديد
الان وهذا هذه معرفه يريدون
يمسك بزمام الامور ولكن حقيقه الامر وما
يشعرون بمتابعه في العلم هناك فراغ
على السطح هناك صراع ضد الدكتور الى رفض
ولا انقلاب الان وتصريحات قبل يومين هناك
التسريبات عمل
سلطه
غير رسميه تحالف الوطن الام الشرعيه تقول
لهم احنا ممكن يفرض على بعض الناس بس هذا
الشارع
يقول الاستاذ العزال هناك تغيرات بالنسبه
للحكام في مصر هناك اضافه الى مقال هناك
ايضا خلافات في لجنه تعديل الدستور
الخمسين هناك خلافات بين اطراف هذه اللجنه
حول مساله الجيش حول مساله مواد الهويه
وهناك ايضا واقع ان هؤلاء القاده الجدد
امام مظاهرات لل استمر في الشارع ونحن
سلام السياسيه ويقول بانه يريد ان يسرع
العمليه انتقاليه اليست هذه مؤشرات على ان
هؤلاء القاده جديد بين قوسين او قاده
الانقلاب في مازق الان
والله
كافه القوى السياسيه في مصر في مازق اما
اي القوى في مازق في مازق اكثر ضيقا فهذا
يعني م لا استطيع ان ناقصه بالضبط ولكن
استطيع ان اقول لك ان مصر في مازق سياسي
وان كافه القوى تعاني منه اه
من ناحيه ال ما ما قيل من ان الغرب يعول
على الجهاز العسكري والامني لتحقيق
الاستقرار في مصر هذا صحيح 1 اسباب ذلك
الهامه هي انا الجهاز العسكري هو اكثر
الاجهزه في مصر استقرارا نقطه اخرى يعني
وانما
قوى ديمقراطيه ناضجه في مصر لكي تستطيع ان
تتعامل معها وليس هذا جانب هذه القوه
اطلاقا انما هي تطورات تاريخيه معينه لان
الناس تعرض والتخريب الدوله باستمرار اه
احب ان اذكرها لحضرتك انه اه زي ما قلت لك
ان هناك قوه اقليميه تؤيد بشده اه مساله
ال المؤسسه العسكريه
والدوله العميقه من الناحيه الاخرى هذه او
اجهزه الحكم الحاليه تواجه احتمال
اضطرابات موجوده في البلد وبعث الدستور
وما الى ذلك خلاصه الكلام انا اتصور ان اه
مصر يعني لن تستقر فيها الامور والسبب
الرئيسي في رايي في هذا ان علاج الامور من
كافه الاطراف السياسيه يتم بالعقليه
التقليديه وطالما قلنا ان المشاكل في مصر
من
من العمق والضخامه انها تحتاج الى عقليه
جديده وليست العقليه التقليديه الى ان
يكتشف القائمون بالامر هذا هذا الموضوع
سوف يبقى المشهد السياسي في تصوري مضطرب
او غير مستقر
سنبحث بعض الفاصل القصير
احتمالات تحقيق الاستقرار في مصر عبر
الاسراف فقط بانهاء المرحله الانتقاليه
المعنى بعد الانقلاب العسكري كما بعد ذلك
فتره نرجع مشاهدينا الكرام
هذا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش ودلالات تحركات القوى
السياسيه المصريه في ضوء محادثات كاثرين
اشتون مسؤوله السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في القاهره اذا كانت الاسهل وهي
في القاهره اه تسمع كلام يعني تقريبا
يطابق لاقاله عمر دراجي اه اه دراجه قيادي
في حزب الحريه والعداله الذي قال بان
المشاكل المصريه مصريه صميمه ولا يمكن ان
تحل الا على يد المصريين وهذا ما قاله
ايضا اه اه متحدث باسم الخارجيه المصريه
كيف نفهم هذا ال الانسجام وتلاقي في مضمون
تصريح ين الحقيقه يعني في ال التحالف
الوطني لدعم الشرعيه وكل ال الحاله يعني
كل القوى السياسيه المناهضه للانقلاب
العسكري في مصر اه تؤمن اما الشان المصري
شان داخلي وتؤمن ان من يستطيع الروحي
الوحيد القادر على تغيير المعادله بكسر
الانقلاب هو استمرار المسار الثوري في مصر
استكمال اهداف خمسه وعشرين هو الشعب
المصري وهذا هو ما كان في خمسه وعشرين
يعني هو ال ال ال هذه النظريه وهذه
القناعه مبنيه على ان نبدا وطني عدم
القبول التدخل في الشان الداخلي من من
الخارجين قد يكون هناك تسهيل لكن ليس
تدخلا لكن الحاجه الثانيه كمان هو اللي
بدات فعلا يعني
خمسه وعشرين خمسه وعشرين الاوروبي وامريكا
اجاوب على السؤال المطروح كمان اللي هو هل
خارطه الطريق يحقق شيء
اولا خطاب السيسى امس قائد الانقلاب يؤكد
انه عنده ازمه في خارطه الطريق يعني احنا
ما نتحدث يجب الاسراع خريطه الطريق
بالمعنى السياسي انه يعاني من ازمه في
خارطه الطريق ايضا انه يريد ان يوصل رساله
للغرب الام الا شكل انه اه يعني احنا
حريصين على الديمقراطيه واحنا كويسين
كلمه الثاني اللي بتهم انما حقيقه الامر
انه الحراك الشعبي ضد هذا الكلام مستمر
ومتزايد
العسكريه امر فيه او ثلاثه ايام او اسبوع
او لا
تاريخ الثوره
هذا الفشل
خارطه الطريق الماضيه
الطريق
هو ما هو عليه الان الاقل يحتضر الان يعني
احنا ما
مؤسسه الحرس القديم والفريق السيسي على
الترشح للرئاسه كل واحد يطلع
الراي العام في هذه الحرب عندما تجد
البرادعي يبتدي بتصريحات
هذا انقلاب وهذا اذا
حينما تجد انه القوى الداعمه
صوره خمسه وعشرين
الثوره الاخرى حتى ضد الاخوان المسلمين
انما التحالف الوطني لدعم الشرعيه اصبح
الوحيد الذي يعني يؤثر بشكل قوي جدا
يدعوا فقط يستجيب الشارع يعني انت عملت
النهار ده
ماذا بعد ماذا بعد
لا بد من العوده الى المسار الديمقراطي
يعني انت
الى الديمقراطيه والانتخابيه كيف تقومون
الاورام خريطه الطريق هذه التي سيكون
قياديين بتخلف نفسها
ان يتحدث مع الدستور الجديد تحدثوا عن
يعني شرف صحفي يعتقلون الصحفيين ويقتلون
تحدثوا عن الحريات والديمقراطيه واعتقل
الالاف الالاف يتحدث عن كثيره جدا
سائرون في الطريق الخاطئ بسرعه اكثر مما
تحتمل
السياسي
هل انت مقتنع اولا فعلا بان الجيش
يعني بكل سطوته على المجتمع على الاقتصاد
على السياسه في مصر على وسائل الاعلام بكل
حضوره
وتاثيره
بهكذا ببساطه عن طريق خارطه الطريق سيتسلم
مقاليد الامور ويسلم القرار
يعني النخبه المدنيه في اطار عمليه
ديمقراطيه حقيقيه
ان اعلق على كلمه حقيقيه في الاخر الذي
مهمه جدا
لكن
الجيش بالتاكيد اه يبحث عن واجهه مدنيه
حكومه مدنيه اه تحكم المشهد المدني بحيث
يبقى هو كما هي حال التركيه يعني تقريبا
الجيش في الثكنات بتاعته عنده يعني
امتيازات معينه وحقوق دستوريه معينه و وضع
اقتصادي معين ويحرص العمليه السياسيه بشكل
او باخر والحكومه المدنيه بتدير الامور اه
كلمه ديمقراطيه حقيقيه اه هذا يعني امر
غير مؤكد ان تكون حقيقيه يعني السبب في
هذا الى ان القوى الفاعله في المشهد
السياسي في واقع الامر ليست في جوهرها قوى
ديمقراطيه اه اصيله سواء ويكون لا نتحدث
عن التيار الاسلامي وهو في رايي بالتاكيد
غير ديمقراطي واذا كان يدعو الديمقراطيه
فان ما يدعو لا من باب الدكتور وهناك تيار
ال ال الدوله العميقه الذي يعني ليس له
سجل ديمقراطي اطلاقا وبالتالي اه القوى
الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه الموجوده في الشارع
ومعظمها قوه شبابيه ليست لديها الموارد
الكافيه ولا التنظيمات الكافيه ولا
التنسيق الكافي لكي تستطيع ان تقف على قدم
المساواه مع القوى الاسلاميه وقوى الدوله
العميقه لهذا السبب اعتقد ان اذا حدث تحول
نحو الديمقراطيه فسوف يقول تحولا في شكل
عمليه ومسار وربما تشوبه كثير من
الاعتراضات
قال امس ان القوات المسلحه لم تدعم طرفا
اه اه سياسيا على حساب طرف اخر وان الشعب
سيختار من يحكمه هل تصدقون ان هذا الكلام
طبعا يعني
الفريق احساسي في معظم الاحاديث التي
قالها اه لم يكن صادقا مع الشعب المسلم
الكتب عليه اه
يعني كل ما استطيع ان اقول لك لكن الوقت
لها لكن هو ال اه يعني
الشارع الشارع
على المسؤولين المصريين يعني قال كل شيء
من الاخوان سيكون جزء من العمليه السياسيه
كثير
يمكن يمكن
يمكن احنا مش انقلاب على الشرعيه يعني
هناك الكثير من الذي قاله خلف اننا خليني
اقول لحضرتك انه ال ال الحكم على من هو
الديمقراطيه ومن ليست ديمقراطيين هو
الاحتكام الى العمليه الديمقراطيه نفسها
يعني انا لا استطيع هنا في الاستوديو
الاستاذ وهي الكامل في الاستوديو ان نحكم
على
في الاستوديو نحكم على
الديمقراطيه او ندخل في نوايا الناس ولكن
احنا في مسار ديمقراطي بعد الثوره خمسه
وعشرين حتى لو كان فيه جزء من القصور لا
شك ولكن الديمقراطيه نفسها بنفسها فاذا
اردنا ان نسير في الطريق الديمقراطي فلابد
ان نحترم طالب عليه ولا يمكن ان يصلح
بالقوه وبالذات التدخل العسكري سيدي ما
يحدث فى مصر الان هو ما ارادت المسلحه
خمسه وعشرين وهو ما اشار اليه الفريق
ولكن لم يحدث
هذه المره كانت هذه
هو من غير السلطه لكن تريد ان تهيمن على
الحكم المدني في مصر والشعب المصري الذي
يريد ان يمتلك شكره يحترم سلطه ال الجيش
في اطار السلطه العامه التي يضعها الشعب
رئيس حزب الوسط المسيحي العام
وايضا مخترقه من رئيس تحالف المصريين
الامريكيين
واشنطن
هذه الحلقه من برنامج خبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قرار
شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته